Процес вербування ув'язнених з російських колоній для участі у війні в Україні вперше потрапив на відео.
Запис зроблено, ймовірно, у виправній колонії номер 6 республіки Марій Ел.
Промову перед ув'язненими виголошує людина, дуже схожа на підприємця Євгена Пригожина,
відомого як "кухар Путіна". В одній із його компаній це відео прокоментували так.
"Справді, ми можемо підтвердити, що людина на відео жахливо схожа на Євгена Вікторовича.
Судячи з його риторики, він якимось чином займається питаннями реалізації завдань "спецоперації",
і, схоже, це успішно виходить. ... І людина, схожа на Євгена Вікторовича, дуже зрозуміло пояснює простому народу прості зрозумілі речі.
Ось один із прикладів того, що в прес-службі компанії "Конкорд" називають "простими та зрозумілими речами":
Людина, "жахливо схожа на Євгена Пригожина", розповідає ув'язненим, які відбувають термін за найважчими статтями,
що для них участь у війні - найкоротший шлях до свободи.
На вихідних онлайн-видання SOTA поширило листування в чаті між одним із ув'язнених колонії в республіці Марій Ел з його колишньою дівчиною.
З переписки також випливає, що ПВК "Вагнер" примусово набирає ув'язнених для відправки на війну, обіцяючи їм гроші та амністію через пів року.
На думку німецького експерта Штефана Майстера, це свідчить про відчай російської сторони,
яка використовує такі методи вербування солдатів для війни в Україні.
Гадаю, це засвідчує також, що таким чином Пригожин просуває себе (або свої інтереси) у Кремлі,
що він робить усе можливе, щоб стати важливим партнером у війні Росії проти України.
Це відео також свідчить про жорстокість та культуру насильства в Росії, яку ми, на жаль, бачимо і про яку ми знаємо.
Тому тональність цього відео і вся ця сцена також викликають питання просто тому, що це абсурдно,
що вони докотилися до того, що вербують людей у в'язницях.
Напередодні члени Ради з прав людини при президенті Росії звернулися до генпрокурора країни з проханням
роз'яснити, на якій підставі "тисячі ув'язнених з невідбутими термінами за різні, в тому числі тяжкі злочини" вирушають на війну в Україні.
Текст звернення опубліковано на сайті Правозахисної ради Санкт-Петербурга.
На думку правозахисників, слова про помилування ув'язнених, які вступили до лав ПВК "Вагнер",
означають остаточний крах російської правової системи.
Немає суду, вироків, ухвал. Неважливо, кому людина відрізала голову і кого вбила - якщо вона присягає на вірність Пригожину
і каже, що вона братиме участь у військовій агресії, її звільняють від покарання, їй дають свободу,
зброю, гроші та використовують її найстрашніші, найнижчі якості.
Для мене це питання моралі: деякі люди - серйозні злочинці, вони вчинили злочини різного ступеня тяжкості,
і тепер вони повинні йти на цю війну просто тому, що немає можливості мобілізувати достатньо інших людей.
Тобто вони свого роду гарматне м'ясо. Адже ці люди переважно не є навченими і підготовленими солдатами.
Але, звісно ж, викликає занепокоєння і те, що люди, які, можливо, вбивали інших, тепер мають змогу купити собі волю, воюючи на цій війні.
Тим часом сама можливість залишитися живими через пів року інтенсивних боїв багатьма оцінюється як дуже примарна.
Найперший загін, який вступив у бій 14 липня, отримає звільнення, якщо це все правда, 15 січня.
На сьогоднішній день з цього загону з 42 осіб живими залишилися лише двоє.
При цьому говорять про високі шанси померти від рук своїх же "бойових товаришів".
Тобто він прямо говорить про те, що якщо людина, потрапивши туди, навіть наступного дня скаже
"тут щось не те, мене не влаштовує, я хочу повернутися", то вони її оголошують дезертиром і без суду та слідства розстрілюють.
Правозахисники впевнені, що ув'язнених використовуватимуть на війні як гарматне м'ясо, а сама ідея з їхнім вербуванням цинічна та нелюдська.
Тілами ув'язнених розміновують українські мінні поля. Тому що ми бачимо, що основна причина смерті ув'язнених - це підрив на міні.
Друга причина - підірвав себе гранатою при спробі оточення чи полону.
Так, це могилізація, утилізація зайвого населення, яке завдає багато проблем.
Тим часом серед ув'язнених кількість охочих вирушити на війну доволі велика.
За різними оцінками, це від 20 до 30 відсотків контингенту кожної виправної установи.
Разом з тим, на думку західних експертів, цікавим видається той факт, що умовний "Пригожин" на відео говорить саме про війну, а не про спецоперацію.
У цьому відео він визнає, що це війна і що це жорстока війна.
У принципі, це суперечить усім публічним заявам, у тому числі російській пропаганді, про те, що це нібито не війна.
Ця людина каже, що Росія цю війну виграє. Отже, тут ідеться про більш реалістичний образ цієї війни,
і це показує, під яким тиском перебуває режим. І те, що таке відео все-таки було опубліковано і що воно змогло пройти через цензуру і не було заблоковано.
Тож для мене це, зрештою, ознака певної паніки чи скрутної ситуації, в якій опинилася Росія та російська армія.
Тим часом сам Пригожин прокоментував ситуацію словами: "Або ПВК і зеки - або ваші діти".